welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a full series breakdown
compilation of Star Wars Rebel season 1
Season 2 Season 3 and season 4 the full
series originally on Disney XD from 2014
to 2018 now streaming on Disney plus and
required viewing for every new Star Wars
liveaction series it seems what you are
watching here is an extended compilation
video of the four separate Rebels
breakdowns that we already released on
the new Rockstar Channel and we are
re-releasing them here as this one Mega
comp old video podcast of sorts at the
request of viewers who preferred
watching this recap series that way
without having to figure out playlists
or hunt down video after video so if you
already watched those four videos thank
you so much you're welcome to watch this
one as well but we just wanted to have a
place for the marathon ventur to have it
their way don't worry new rock stars is
not going to become like a reupload
channel this is just going to be
something that we do every once in a
while when it makes sense to do it and
at the end of this breakdown compilation
I'm going to share my list of which
Rebels episodes I think are must watches
if you only have time to watch like a
season's worth of episodes as well as my
ranking of the top five best Rebels
episodes we should have a video Chapter
down below that you can click to if you
just want to skip right to that portion
but for everyone else here we go enjoy
past me breaking down all four seasons
of rebels for you season 1 episode one
and two spark of the Rebellion Parts one
and two this two-part series premiere
opens on the Triangular holes of three
Imperial Star Destroyers looking like
sharp teeth of the jaws of a beast
chomping down on the Stars devouring the
Galaxy George Lucas's opening shot for a
New Hope was also a star destroyer
bearing down on us and that's where this
Rebel series wants to put us emotionally
James Earl Jones returns to voice Darth
Vader whose mask we see in a massive
screen encompassing hologram the Jedi
Knights are all but destroyed and yet
your task is not complete Inquisitor and
the Baldhead positioned right invader's
breathing vent breathing down on his
shoulders and his head is that of The
Inquisitor where the grand Inquisitor
voiced by Jason Isaacs the utan race
scene in Revenge of the Sith in the
Obi-Wan Kobi series he was played by
rert friend but they really didn't do
enough to stretch out his face while he
would go on to be known as the grand
Inquisitor at first in this Rebel series
the character was known as just The
Inquisitor originally Rebels wasn't
going to have Darth Vader at all but
they decided to add this prologue and
the epilogue of the series for context
and star warness Lucas film released
rebels in October 2014 on Disney XD
after Clone Wars was discontinued on the
Cartoon Network in 2013 with an
unfinished season 6 Arc moved to Netflix
Rebels would send around all new
characters and be set in five BBY that's
5 years before A New Hope and about 14
years after Revenge of the Sith over the
course of this series it would progress
ahead to right before A New Hope Ezra
Bridger the hero really of this series
voiced by Taylor Gray looks out from a
tower on the Outer Rim world of lothal
this backdrop is kind of Ezra's binary
Sunset it returns throughout the series
specifically in the final shot of the
series and we'll see it in the Ahsoka
series and Ahsoka the character will be
played by Iman nanii Ezra's view of the
Star Destroyer blast The Imperial
March
yes really all of John Williams themes
just come back throughout this series so
I'm not going to be pointing out every
instance nor will they point out like
every species every ship every Droid
every little bit of random orbes I'm
really just going to focus on the major
major stuff that you need to know for
the other titles and the really really
cool Easter eggs that I don't really
think anyone else has pointed out before
so lothal is currently under Imperial
occupation and so we see all over the
place propaganda like this mural with
orbes text support your Empire build Tie
fighters the lus in defense against
threats to peace Sina Fleet systems
bringing jobs and prosperity to lothal
this is really what lothal is currently
used for by the Empire signer Fleet
systems the company that builds Tie
fighters later thron will use lothal and
had he been successful in that operation
the Empire might not have lost the Civil
War Ezra who's Force sensitive senses
his future Master Kanan jerus voiced by
Freddy Prince
Jr that was weird
I yeah I I love this sound effect of
Ezra sensing the force and it's
presented as kind of a force of nature
here almost like a whale call in the
hyperspace whales the perill will play a
very important role in Ezra's Destiny
and will appear in the Ahsoka series
Kanan jerus is the Alias of the former
Jedi Caleb Doom Apprentice to DEA balaba
and their tragic Order 66 moment was
depicted in the very first episode of
the bad batch series also in his crew
here in the streets of lothal is Zeb
aurelios the lasat voed by Steve Bloom
who also showed up in live action with
Incredible VFX in the Mandalorian season
3 and the Mandalorian character Sabine
Ren voiced in this series by Tia sirar
who is played in Ahsoka by Natasha Louis
bizo Sabine is quite the artist her
armor features the Mandalorian starboard
symbol the orbes number five for her
code name being Spectre 5 and a night
owl style helmet the same kind of style
worn by bokatan Ezra interrupts these
Rebels mission to steal blasters leading
to this Chase through the loal streets
and down the highway they get scooped up
by the ghost a vcx1 100 light Raider
captained by twick Hara suula voiced by
Vanessa Marshall in this show and played
by Mary Elizabeth Winstead and Ahsoka
and their astrom Droid is Chopper voiced
by Dave Fon himself and as we'll see in
pretty much every episode of the series
Chopper is just kind of a jerk he's
always picking fights and committing
more crimes Ezra finds a lightsaber in
Jedi holocron that has a message to all
Jedi from Obi-Wan Kenobi right after the
purge and Obi-Wan here is voiced by
James Arnold Taylor doing a pretty solid
impression of you and McGregor this is
Master Obi-Wan Kenobi I regret to report
that both our Jedi Order and the
Republic have fallen but it's
interesting how in the super Premiere we
only hear the first half of it here we
don't get the full message of Hope just
yet now these blasters are sold to Crim
Lord vizago in exchange for food and
info about Wii Prisoners the ghost crew
tries to pull the old wook prisoner con
that H and chewy pulled in A New Hope
except Kanan and Sabine pretend that Zeb
is a rare hairless wook haven't you ever
seen a rare hairless W
before it's all a trap though and Ezra
gets captured by agent Callis voiced by
the amazing actor David O Yello the crew
goes back for Ezra who had overheard
where the wooki prisoners are because
he's such a crafty thief and voice
impersonator on stolen radio coms so the
wookies are being sent into slave labor
in the spice mines on the planet Kastle
of Kastle run Fame and would be shown a
few years later in live action in the
solo film they free these Wookies and
Kanan Reveals His Jedi skills we get a
little willhelm scream when Ezra rescues
a Wookie kid and Kanan offers to train
Ezra in the ways of the force and we
hear the rest of Obi-Wan's hopeful
message and how it's not just a warning
it's a message of Hope and advice on how
to move forward from this our future is
uncertain we will each be challenged our
trust our faith our friendships and in
time A New Hope will emerge ah a new
hope it's the name of the movie okay
episode three droids in distress the
ghost crew plats to steal ion disruptors
from Minister MTH Tua now Tua is a
character that appears in the thron
novel and in a few Star Wars comics RTD2
and C3PO Cameo so folks season 1 of
rebels an attempt to win over Star Wars
fans often just plugged in random faces
from the OT but my favorite Cameo here
is a Droid pil in this gell transport
rx24 voiced by The Wonderful Paul Rubin
who we just lost I am sorry sir your
Astromech must proceed to the back of
the craft ruin is an important voice to
Star Wars history he provided the voice
of r3x or Rex from the original Star
Tours ride at Disneyland and r3x now
serves as a DJ at ogus Cantina in
Galaxy's Edge 3PO and R2 translate for
Tua and they end up on board the ghost
we learned that ion disruptors are the
weapons that wiped out most of zeb's
people the lasat so he's wory about this
deal but callus shows up during their
meeting with vizago and taunts Zeb with
a bow rifle that he says he took off a
lat and he says that he's the one who
gave the order to use those Ion
disruptors on them all and Zeb loses it
and while zeb's about to lose this fight
Ezra Force pushes callus away from Zeb
and the crew Returns the protocol and
Astromech droids to their owner Senator
Bale Orana the final shot of this
episode mirrors Leia recording her
message to Obi-Wan on R2 in A New Hope
okay episode four fighter flight Ezra
and Zeb after some squabbling go on a
meu run run the meu Run Fruit comeb back
throughout liveaction Star Wars titles
daone loves these and you can actually
get a drink based on the mun at Galaxy's
Edge it's so good yeah this episode is
kind of all about the fruit the fruit
really is one of the simple joys of
being a rebel folks and the shopping
list that Hera gives them includes
science dip space waffles large bag
writing Cam and Dill Pickles Ezra runs
into family friend Morad sumar and Ze
and Ezra find a crate of murun and Ezra
gets caught stealing one of them they
escape in a tiei while Hera and Kanan
hang out back on the ghost playing Holo
chess Zeb and Ezra chase down the
prisoner Convoy in the tie that's not
the tie you're looking for yeah ze's
trying to pull off some classic Jedi
Mind Tricks the way Ezra has been
scratching the surface of using the
force these first four episodes this
Imperial troop transport we see is
actually based on a classic Star Wars
toy you know where the people kind of
plug into the sides of it and we see Al
saine graffitied a mural of Zeb and Ezra
an Chopper she is such a talented artist
something that will come back in the
final scene of the series throughout the
show you do get shots of her room that
includes characters that look a lot like
CAD Bane and embo from Clone Wars
episode five rise of the old master so
this is an important episode please
watch this one if you can it's really
good Kanan trains Ezra using these same
methods that Yoda uses with Luke
Skywalker an Empire the one-armed
handstand and this line do or do not
there is no try what does that even mean
so these Yoda anecdotes will be
important to Ezra since he later
communes with the Jedi Master and this
episode explores really the deeper
meaning of that quote from Empire which
I think often goes misunderstood because
I think people think that if you can't
actually accomplish something you
shouldn't even try that's not really
what it means it really means begin with
the end in mind see your target
actualize it believe in yourself and set
your Target on the destination don't
prematurely commit yourself to a half
measure Ezra nearly falls to his
freaking death from this training and
pitchy machine Chopper fires another
bottle at Ezra and lands on a loat and
these fuzzballs our beloved creatures
that filon loves to bring back in live
action I'm sure we're going to see quite
a few Lo cats in Ahsoka the Imperial
news channel gets hijacked by the
anti-empire senator in Exile Travis
voiced by Brent Spiner from Star Trek
the Next Generation spy Master luminar
unduli is apparently imprisoned in the
spire luminar and dully first appeared
in Attack of the Clones and she showed
up in Clone Wars as a master of Baris AI
the young Jedi who framed ahsokatano for
the bombing of the Jedi Temple which led
to Ahsoka leaving the Jedi Order the
Spire meanwhile is where Maul was
actually held in the comic Darth Maul
son of damir where he was imprisoned by
Darth cidus in the part of the timeline
that set after Clone War season 5 Kanan
and Ezra make it to Julie cell and
realize that it's not actually her it's
a corpse and the grand Inquisitor was
using her Essence to lure in the Jedi as
Kanan and The Inquisitor duel The
Inquisitor taunts him close quter
fighting bava's emphasis was always on
form three which you favor to ridicul
degree clearly you were a poor student
now this Inquisitor used to be a Jedi
Temple guard and he was there for the
trials of Ahsoka embarrass in that Clone
Wars ARC and he mentions form three
there are seven total forms of
lightsaber combat and form three is most
defensive one and this is also the first
time we see the inquisitor's rotating
double-bladed lightsaber put to use Floy
introduced these as kind of a step up
from muls double-sided saber and Phantom
Menace this one spins they escape with
the help of Hera and some horny tibes
the tibes got their name from the
abbreviation TBD or Tob determined the
production team was using TBD as a
placeholder name and they decided to
just go with it which is kind of how a
lot of stuff in Star Wars Works Kanan
discovers a new understanding of Yoda's
quote I'm not going to try to teach you
anymore if all all I do is try that
means I don't truly believe I can
succeed so from now on I will teach you
look I may fail you may fail but there
is no try so this wisdom is as much for
the teacher as it is for the student as
Yoda will later explain in The Last Jedi
which I think is my favorite quote from
the sequel Trilogy failure also yes
failure most of all the greatest teacher
failure is we are what they grow
beyond that that is the true burden of
all Masters so really Yoda's wisdom is
the rise of the Old Masters in this
episode's title okay episode 6 breaking
ranks Ezra goes under cover at an
imperial Academy posing his Cadet named
Dev Morgan to steal a key card to stop a
shipment of kyber crystals which power
lightsabers and eventually power the
Death Star which is why at the end of
this episode the transport explodes
releasing a wild green shock wave Ezra
and the other Cadets are tested using
this well its design is inspired by
Clone Wars episodes with the clone
troopers clone Cadets and the Box the
clone troopers have all since been
decommissioned excluding the bad batch
some of whom are still alive at this
point in the timeline as well as Rex
whom will meet in future seasons of
rebels and I guess that Homeless one
that Obi-Wan ran into in the Obi-Wan
Kenobi series but they've all been
replaced with Imperial recruits in the
form of Stormtroopers and this is how
they're trained Ezra gets Call's key
card to the ghost crew but he stays
behind to break out his friends Jael and
Zer leonis who's actually also
undercover trying to find his sister Dar
who went missing from the academy the
grand inquisitors is coming the next day
to take custody of Ezra and Jai and the
three fight their way out of the academy
and an at EST with the help of the ghost
crew but Zar decides to stay behind to
continue to search for his sister and he
faces the grand inquisitors questioning
episode s out of Darkness so the Phantom
which is a small ship attached to the
ghost gets damaged in this episode Zeb
fails to notice a leak so Hera and
Sabine take the Phantom to collect
supplies from a contact named fulcrum on
Fort Anais which is an abandoned
asteroid base and Anais will later be
Revisited in the bad batch Arc of Clone
Wars season 7 which is set years before
this when the base was still active
during the Clone Wars in their fight
against the droid army the separatists
har sine find fulcrum's crates marked
with a fulcrum symbol which yes does
look a bit like a certain tudus head
more on that later of course but Anais
is infested with furox which are deadly
and sunlight averse with an asteroid
about to block out the sun and the
Phantom out of fuel Hera and Sabine have
to use the explosive rhydonium to hold
them off rhydonium was actually seen in
the season 5 abaar episodes of Clone
Wars in this episode we also finally get
to see some space waffles which were on
hara's shopping list in episode 4
Galaxy's Edge needs these on the menu
okay episode 8 Empire day Kanan trains
Ezra to use the force to connect with a
loath cat but Ezra can't focus because
it's empire Day celebrating the founding
of the Empire 15 years ago we also find
out that it's the same day as Ezra's
birthday he turned 15 he was born the
day the empire was founded and8 years
ago is when the Empire took his parents
Ephraim and Mera he hasn't seen them
since he is an orphan kind of like
Aladdin we see the Imperial holet
broadcast which I am fascinated by we
get a look at Palpatine and this image
in the broadcast is from his younger
days before he became you know a hunched
raisin that shoots lightning show me how
really Imperial propaganda is hiding his
true appearance I like the ores ticker
here it translates to Residents attacked
by herd of rabid loath cats tragedy at
boo boo Barn also part of his propaganda
is the music on this broadcast which
also we hear during the parade an upbeat
version of The Imperial March by
composer Kevin
Kleiner so this music is something that
exists in Universe for the characters we
also heard this Imperial Propaganda
music in Solo the ghost crew throw
grenades that turn out to be fireworks
diversions later when they the two death
stars blow up in the original timeline
those explosions are kind of celebrated
as literal fireworks in the sky Tua and
oresco show off the new Sinar Tha
Advance V1 the rebels blow it up Ezra
takes them to his old house where they
find sibo that's the missing Rodan of
this episode The Empire put Tech in his
head that's giv him access to schematics
battle plans including at-ats or at ATS
tie interceptors and Sabine mentions an
encrypted file talking about a 5year
plan for outer imp planets which might
refer to project Stardust that's a plan
to build a death star cuz about 5 years
from now is when that will go online
they get sibo off the planet and he
reveals he knows what happens to Ezra's
parents to be continued and we pick up
from there in episode 9 Gathering forces
when Tie fighters are now chasing The
Ghost and sibo tells Ezra that Troopers
took his parents away he was too afraid
to stop them or to help raise Ezra and
Ezra is pissed The Inquisitor has
attached an XX 23 S thread tracker to
the Phantom right before the ghost jumps
to hyperspace the sread tracker was
first introduced in kraken's Rebel Field
Guide which is a 1991 Star Wars RPG
guide book sio knows there's a tracker
on board though and Kanan erra detach
the Phantom mid hyperspace to misdirect
The Inquisitor they take the Phantom to
an axis where Ezra tries to connect with
the foox using the force an animal
taming ability that Star Wars titles
have been exploring more and more like
grou with the rancor Ezra admits that
he's not afraid of the feox he's afraid
of not knowing the truth about his
parents so he forgives sibo and he tames
these beasts who look at Ezra in a way
I'm always trying to get my dog Darla to
do it me but she won't the fear Knox
occupy the Storm Troopers while the
grand Inquisitor fights Kanan gives them
the business Ezra unsummon the alpha
fock using some dark side of the forest
Powers they managed to escape but uhoh
keep this in mind Ezra's Dark Side
Affinity just becomes increasingly
important throughout the series but this
episode ends with sub giving us a bit of
Hope restoring an image of Ezra with his
parents episode 10 path of the Jedi
another important one Canan brings Ezra
to a hidden Jedi Temple on lothal after
that dark side of the forest incident
the temple demands both master and
Padawan open it together but once
they're inside Ezra must face the
challenges alone in a way he kind of has
to save his master it's actually kind of
similar to Luke Skywalker's cave quest
in Empire strikes back or Ray in that
cave and achto in The Last Jedi like
Luke and Ray Ezra faces his worst fears
and his insecurities a vision of Canan
killed by The Inquisitor and then the
ghost crew talking some major about
him The Inquisitor Slaughters them too
but Ezra manages to snap himself out of
it to make it through the first few
challenges and he hears Yoda's voice
once again voiced by Frank Oz big fears
have you faced young one who are you a
guide Yoda also guides kanan's
insecurities as a master because it's as
important to teach the master Yoda is an
exile on DEA at this point in history so
it's just kind of nice to hear that he
mentally calls out to so many Jedi
survivors scattered across the Galaxy
during this point in history in the
temple we see etchings on the walls
these were actually inspired by Ralph
mcc's illustration in The Illustrated
Star Wars Universe from 1995 and it
seems like we'll learn more about these
kinds of etchings in Ahsoka Ezra
acquires a kyber crystal for his future
lightsaber and when Ezra asks Kanan if
they should use the temple as a base
Kanan just says I know what's in there
the past the past because he knows the
Jedi already tried to use the Jedi
Temple as a sanctuary the Jedi Temple on
corant the one that was purged and
Obi-Wan explained in his message the
Jedi are now on A New Path they are
homeless Nomads episode 11 idiots array
it's the Lando episode Billy D Williams
returns to voice of famous Smuggler
beating Zeb in a game of saach and
winning Chopper name's kissian Lando
kissian now please introduce me to my
new Droid his winning hand is idiots
array it's a winning hand in the name
saach the rules of the game were
detailed in the Lando novel from 1983
the crew joins Lando on a smuggling run
and they meet as Morgan voiced by the
great James Hong who recently appeared
in everything everywhere at once his
design was inspired by an early rough
mccor design for job by the Hut actually
I have what you
ordered what do you have to offer and
return Lando offers Hera too as Morgan
but it's part of his supposed plan to
get a puffer Pig who can detect Precious
Minerals and puff up when it gets scared
Herod does manage to escape and makes it
back to the ghost where she punches
Lando for using her the ghost gets past
the Imperial blockade and returns to
lothal where as Morgan waits for them
his big shootout and Ezra Reveals His
new lightsaber but it's also a Blaster
gun which you know every lightsaber
should have that functionality they
drive as Morgan off and they leave land
behind with his piggy episode 12 vision
of hope so Ezra has a vision of Senator
and Exile Travis including the crew
helping Travis hide and Travis
mentioning Ezra's parents which matches
up with Travis's conveniently time coded
broadcast that he is actually headed to
loal so they think they must meet up
with him Ezra meets up with Zar who says
that callus gathered troops at the old
Senate building and the rebels try to
warn Travis that callus is setting up a
trap but callus and Tua are one step
ahead of them with Intel on all of the
rebels they escape into the seers with
Travis who reveals himself to be an
Imperial spy son of a he used
those Transmissions to smoke out Rebel
sympathizers senator be Travis also
tells Ezra that his parents are long
dead your parents were very very brave
and very foolish where are they now I'll
tell you my boy they're gone but
good news is Hara suspected Travis was
sus and she punched him after giving him
a dud Blaster so they escaped callus and
the Storm Troopers and Ezra threw the
blades that fan throws one Epic Death
Stare back at Travis before he takes off
episode 13 call to action so The
Inquisitor antua and callus greet Grand
mof Tarkin on lothal so Tarkin asks why
the rebels keep making gains in Clone
Wars Tarkin was still just an admiral
but bad bat kind of shows them in that
transition from then to now here we see
him wearing armor similar to what
general veers wore and Empire Strikes
Back Travis outs the ghost crew to the
public with the reward for their capture
so they can't hide in plain sight
anymore maybe you should change your
armor saine and Kanan plans to send a
message hijacking Imperial broadcast
from a communication tower on lothal but
Tarkin allows The Inquisitor to execute
oresco and Grant Tarkin facing away from
them underlining this really is the
message to Tua and callus to get their
together Ezra finally connects to a
loaf cat to clear a Prov Droid but at
they end up getting recorded by the
playback The Inquisitor ambushes them at
the tower capturing Kanan but Ezra
manages to transmit an inspiring call to
action stand up together because that's
when we're strongest and although the
tower gets blown up the final seconds of
this episode and not with the theme
music but with this interesting Fade Out
sound effect this isn't over no it
isn't I like to think their radio
message was still playing over Hera and
Ezra's final exchange there and that
authentic uncertainty that hot mic
moment also went out to inspire the
people episode 14 Rebel resolve fulgram
tells Hara you must stop your search for
Kanan and go into hiding Now fulgrim's
voice is sounding more feminine showing
how they're getting closer to revealing
her identity ahsokatano also had to
forget about her Jedi Master and going
to hiding after Order 66 they intercept
the Droid Courier and swap it with
chopper who infiltrates the Imperial
systems and steals some info Chopper
pushes an Astromech off the go ghost
zeb's reaction here is just great but
that astrom survives he just kind of
trembles between two loats still pretty
mean for Chopper to do that they read
the file on Kanan and it lists his past
crimes including theft of Imperial
supplies resisting arrest assaulting
officers and piloting without a license
after some torture Kanan is taken to
Mustafar current home to Darth Vader's
castle and Hera describes it as that
Mustafar is where Jedi go to die as it
was here where the Jedi Anakin was
overtaken killed if you will by The Sith
Lord Vader and episode 15 fire across
the Galaxy the season 1 finale the ghost
crew steals an imperial transport and as
it takes off the smoke exhaust and dust
forms the curved swishes of the Rebel
Insignia nice touch there the tie that
Ezra and Zeb stole on lothal in episode
4 comes back but saine has painted it
making it look as ridiculously flashy
and dumbass you know a spy trying to
blend in would if she painted her
Mandalorian armor that way whatever the
shows for kids The Inquisitor knows that
physical torture isn't working so he's
using kanan's guilt over abandoning his
master and the Jedi to try to break him
Kanan recalls dea's last word to him run
again this is something we will actually
see in the bad patch it's a
heartbreaking moment run the rebels use
pulse detonators to disable Tark and
Star Destroyer reinforcements are sent
in though so Chopper contacts fulcrum
and every time we see her her Hood I
think back in 2014 I just remember
thinking this is probably Leia right but
the reveal of who really is so much
better as refreeze Kanan and The
Inquisitor is waiting for them both the
three of them duel with lightsabers
Kanan at one point using Ezra Ezra at
one point using kanan's the two one duel
evoking the climax of phantom menace
it's so great and asra gets thrown off
the bridge Kanan thinks he's dead and
thinking he has nothing left to fear
he's able to beat back The Inquisitor
and The Inquisitor throws himself into
the fire leaving us with some chilling
final words you have no idea what you've
unleashed here today there are some far
more frightening than death ah in this
one line we sense the tortured life that
these inquisitors lived when they're
living under Vader in the emperor the
rebels are saved by some corellian
Cruisers with the hollow projection of
Senator Bale Orana and finally reveal
the agent fulcrum who is not Leia Orana
but Ahsoka Tano so what happens now I
don't know one chapter has closed for
you Ezra Bridger this is a new day A New
Beginning Ahsoka T in 2014 we had last
seen Ahsoka in the Clone War series
season 5 leaving Anakin behind there
were some unfinished story lines that
were going to be released on Netflix but
it was so cool to see her again now in
2020 asoka's immediate aftermath of
Clone Wars season 5 was shown in Clone
Wars final season season 7 on Disney
plus ahsoka's time between would be
explored in the 2016 ekek Johnson novel
Ahsoka part of which was adapted in an
episode of tales of the Jedi in 2022 but
here theyve aged up Snips by 15 years
she's got longer Snips the stripes are
stretched downward still voiced by
Ashley Xin though Rosario Dawson plays
her in live action now really the
character just keeps showing up at all
different times in history as season 1
began with Vader's face so it ends as
Tarson tells callus that the emperor has
sent an alternative solution and whereas
episode 13 ended with the broadcast d
out over the title now episode 15 ends
with this
[Music]
sound really Rebel season 1 I think was
still find in its footing it was fun but
it really just gets better from here
season 2 will Explore More of the ghost
crew's back Stories redel season 2
episodes 1 and two the siege of loal
Parts one and two the ghost crew now
works for the rebel Phoenix Squadron led
by jonato and including ahsokatano Ezra
you will notice still has his scar from
he and kanan's fight with The Inquisitor
in the season 1 finale just a bit of
nice continuity for this series that it
sticks with as it continues just to show
Ezra's brushes with the dark side stay
with him Lord Vader shakes down Minister
Tua and we get a closeup of his
outstretched hand gesturing toward Tua
scene by Callis like he knows this high-
ranking wizard is known to force choke
officers and this season we start to see
how Callis starts to have second
thoughts about his loyalties Tua reaches
out to the rebels to effect offering a
list of Rebel synthesizers on lothal and
the true reason the emperor cares about
lothal but to it shuttle explodes
Invader blames the rebels and the
Bridger home is destroyed Ezra also
later sees Tarkin Town another possible
Refuge going up in smoke so like Luke
Skywalker and Star Wars you can't go
home again as they try to escape Ezra
and Kanan sense a cold presence and boom
Vader red lightsaber same POS he strikes
in the Rogue one killbox he takes it to
Ezra and Kanan one-handed and he seems
to just be playing with them but why
really he wants them to escape so that
he can track them to the rest of the
Rebel Fleet which brings us to this
crucial moment when Vader turns to look
out of his cockpit at sensing a presence
he hasn't felt since and this moment is
so good the fear the anger the
hate it's the C Lord we fixed The
Apprentice
lives fear leads to anger anger leads to
hate hate leads to Vader mother she
assumed Anakin was dead this season
shows a sooka in denial of this truth
that Anakin is the same person as Vader
and I don't think she really believes it
until she actually sees that face
beneath the mask in the season finale
Vader communicates with Palpatine voiced
here by Sam witor and he tells the
emperor that The Apprentice of Skywalker
lives this is an opportunity we cannot
let pass Skywalker Apprentice could lead
us to other lost Jedi such as Kenobi
yeah quite a few promises made here for
this season Vader Ahsoka rematch Whit
we's voice tells us that the animated
version of maul maybe in the works and
someday later in this series we'll get
the return of
Kobi three the Lost commanders Ahsoka
sends the ghost crew to the steelos
system to find somebody that she used to
know Rex former clone trooper from the
51st and later the 332nd companies
recurring companion to ahsokatano and
Anakin and Kenobi and Clone Wars he's
joined by Gregor and wolf Gregor's shirt
has a power sliders logo on it power
sliders was a diner on abaar where
Gregor was a dishwasher for a bit Gregor
agrees to help them find a base location
if they use Zea's bait to catch a jupa
that's a giant worm creature that they
could feed on for a year this scene
where they catch it totally un omage to
Jaws Kanan doesn't trust clones after
Order 66 of course but Rex says that
they never betray the Jedi because they
removed their control chips and you can
see a scar on their heads from where
those chips were surgically removed a
process that we see on Rex in the Clone
Wars season 7 finale Rex tells Ezra a
great Jedi once told me that the best
leaders lead by example something that
must have been said to him by Anakin
when Rex served under his command during
the Clone Wars but wolf ratted them out
an imperial drone damages a Phantom
episode four relics of the Old Republic
stranded on steelos Rex offers a few
possible Rebel B sites and the other two
are like you know what I'm actually done
with war agent callus arrives with
at-ats or at ATS on the horizon an aage
to how these things were first
introduced on Hoth and Empire Strikes
Back Ezra uses a force to see through a
sandstorm and Fires at a weak point on
the Walkers callus almost finishes
them just like the old days yeah just
like the old days Clone Wars Rex is back
and we meet a new Inquisitor here the
fifth brother his design was actually
inspired by unused art work for the
force awakens we saw the live action
version of the fifth brother in Obi-Wan
Kenobi played by Sun Kang the rebels
Escape steelos where Rex reunites with
the SOA later it was confirmed that
Gregor and wolf actually stayed behind
and made that last atat their new home
day filon confirmed that there was a
deleted scene that showed this episode 5
always two there are of course a
reference to Yoda's line about the Sith
and Phantom Menace the Sith rule of two
which comes back in the Sith temple on
malachor this season here it refers to
two inquisitors the fifth brother and
the seventh sister who's voiced by Sarah
Michelle Geller Kan and actor Freddy
Prince junior's wife Ezra Sabine and Zeb
and Chopper take the Phantom gets
medical supplies from an Old Republic
medical base it's kind of a scene
straight out of aliens Chopper
encounters an id9 secret Droid pet that
belongs to the seventh sister fifth
brother captures Sabine seventh sister
captures interrogates Ezra about Ahsoka
Zeb and Chopper rescue Ezra and Zine and
Escape back to the rebel Fleet where
Kanan is shocked to learn about these
new inquisitors how many are there
episode 6 Brothers of the broken horn
Rex and Kanan train Ezra they butt heads
over whether one should be a soldier or
a Jedi Ezra says he's not sure if he
wants to be either because our dude is
is in a mood a distressed call comes
from vizago ship remember him from
season 1 the ship is called the broken
horn which has actually been taken over
by Hondo onaka the pirate who also
appeared in the Clone Wars voiced by Jim
Cummings you can also see this character
on the Disneyland Galaxy's Edge ride
Smugglers Run he claims vizago lost the
ship to him in a game of subach an
imperial ship attacks and Chopper and
Ezra fix the ship just in time to jump
to hyperspace Ezra agrees to help anaka
with a deal they talk with the planet
nius to deliver the goods to a buyer as
Morgan you remember him in the Nexus Hub
you can see a bunch of posters on the
walls and including one for the Imperial
Navy that reads the shape of freedom and
protecting the Galaxy with strength and
Justice there's also an ad for the blue
milk that every Star Wars fan knows and
a poster that reads leave it and
hyperdrive Ezra screwing around with an
knocka this episode really helps him
realize that the life of a thief and a
Smuggler is less appealing to him than
the discipline of being a Jedi but is it
the discipline or the Power episode s
wings of the master Kanan and the
Phoenix Squadron try bringing some food
to the oppressed people of ibar Rex
brings up a prototype blockade Buster
that they can find in chanta pole Hara
Sabine and Zeb get through shanta's
tricky atmosphere and the mon calamari
engineer quy saves them from falling off
an edge of the cliff Cory also appears
in the Animated Series Lego Star Wars of
free maker Adventures Cory shows them
this blockade Buster called the
bladewing this ship would eventually
become the b-wing a fighter scen in the
original trilogy didn't get a lot of
screen time though Hera takes control of
the bwing Sabine tells Cory that she'll
fix the blade Wings laser aiming system
never get between a Mandalorian and a
weapons package yeah something to know
about Sabine as a former Imperial
weapons expert she just loves to blow
up the success of this Mission gets
her promoted to Phoenix Squadron leader
episode 8 blood sisters so saine Ezra
and Chopper head to the Havoc Outpost to
intercept a courier which ends up being
the Droid EG 86 Sabine reunites with an
old friend turned Bounty Hunter ketsu
Ono voiced by Gina Torres a firefly Fame
ketu works for a crime syndicate black
son and she's seeking out the EG Droid
through ketu we see what saine's life
could have looked like if she didn't
join the rebellion and we learn that a
pinion to blow up goes further when
there's an imperial Crest on that
episode 9 stealth strike Ezra and
Commander St are captured by an imperial
interdictor light Cruiser which creates
a gravity well strong enough to pull
ships out of hyperspace wow this is the
episode that many of us single out to
accuse Chopper of being a war criminal
because this episode ends with chopper
sabotaging that ship so that it explodes
and takes out two Imperial Cruisers with
it which some estimat online have put
from around 4,500 total deaths to maybe
47,000 deaths I don't know I think it's
probably on the lower end of that but
either way that's a lot of people now
you could say that Luke Skywalker blew
up the Death Star that's a lot of
Stormtroopers but the Death Star was
just about to blow up the re base they
were totally justified they were acting
in defense Chopper meanwhile did not
need to kill this many people okay
episode 10 the future of the force this
episode is the first one to take place
in 3 BBY we're moving ahead in time here
folks closer and closer to the events of
A New Hope Ahsoka realizes that details
about Vader are just kind of hard to
find HM why is that she comes to a
civilian transport that was wiped out by
the seventh sister and the fifth brother
and they go on a rescue mission to
recover some Force sensitive kids aoka
mentions a past incident where four
sensitive kids were taken during the
Clone Wars this is a reference to Clone
Wars season 2 episode 3 Children of the
force where Dar cidia sent CAD Bane
after some kids and so after swearing
off the Jedi Order we see that Ahsoka
has to return to her obligation to the
force users that are out there in the
universe which adds to her guilt that
had she not left Anakin and the order
maybe maybe Anakin might not have fallen
to the dark side in order 66 wouldn't
have been as effective okay episode 11
Legacy this episode aired on December
9th 2015 making it the last Rebels
Episode to air before the force awakens
and the sequel Trilogy just kind of took
everything over Ezra dreams about his
parents in Imperial prison and her Kanan
mentioned hearing about a prison break
the group splits up Ezra and Kanan did
the Phantom till lethal the rest stain
and guell with the ghost to help fend
off the imps and Ezra follows the Lo cat
that he saw in his dream and I'm telling
you Lo cats are just the best and he
meets another prisoner Ryder aadi voiced
by Clancy Brown who tells Ezra that his
parents heard his broadcast from season
1 and that inspired them to organize
their prison break but they died in the
breakout so Kanan Comforts it by telling
them that his parents live inside him
but it's kind of a mixed right of
passage for Ezra while it definitely
hardens his resolve it also Saddles him
with some survivors skilt and reminders
of some personal ties in his life that
just makes him more vulnerable to the
dark side okay episode 12 a princess on
loal the Leia episode Bill Orana picks
his daughter Leia to help the rebels
secure some much needed Cruisers But
It's tricky because while the ghost crew
are all public criminals Leia and Bale
are still pretending to be
diplomatically neutral Leia is voiced
here by Julie Dolan who also voices Leia
in some video games and on the star T's
ride at Disney the plan is a success and
the rebels steal the three Cruisers and
Leia is able to blame the Imperials for
their failure to protect protect them
and inspired by this ryer aadii joins
the rebel cause Okay episode 13 the
protector of conquer Dawn this is an
important episode for the Mandalorian
side of Star Wars titles as conquer Dawn
is one of the moons of Mandalore and the
rebels run into the Mandalorian faction
called the protectors they're led by
Finn raal a former pilot instructor that
Kanan knows from the Battle of middo
this was in an issue of the Star Wars
Kanan comic the symbol on Finn ral's
helmet is based on Joe Johnston's
original designs for Boba Fett before
the making of The Empire Strikes Back
filon named the character after Brad Ral
director of this episode in bunch of
other Star Wars animated stuff including
resistance in the bad batch they pilot
Fang Fighters these ships would also
appear in the Mandalorian season 3 in
chapters 23 and 24 and we learn that
these mandalorians have sided with the
Empire that's right the Mandalorian
factions have some diverse loyalties
which will be important as Seine in
season 3 savine reveals to the
protectors that she is from house visa
and she challenges raal to single combat
working together Kanan and Sabine
capture raal and he agrees to allow the
rebels safe Passage through conquer D
but we learned that even the ghost crew
can be divided by their past loyalties
and their past Liv before the Rebellion
episode 14 Legends of the lat the ghost
crew arrives to nix's HUB 218 this is
the same world that we saw in the
brothers of the broken horn they rescue
a pair of lasats Chava the wise and gron
so Zeb ain't the last of his species
that's good news these two are seeking
the mystical world of Lan where
surviving lasats can find Refuge Zeb
transforms his bow rifle into its true
form and combines it with Chava's staff
revealing liras son's location in the
Uncharted wild space zeev decides to
stay with the ghost crew to continue
looking for lasats another Rebel
choosing to stick with the Rebellion
rather than another life that they could
live but this is the episode that the
ancient names of the sides of the forest
are first revealed by Chava calling the
light side ashla and the dark side Bogan
these get repeated by the bendu in a
later episode of rebels we'll get to him
later but these terms actually come from
early treatments of the first Star Wars
film by George Lucas and ahsoka's name
in early development for Clone Wars is
actually ashla and ashla is a name that
she later takes on as an alias during
her Exile during EK Johnston's novel
episode 15 the call this is the first
appearance of the pgle I mentioned in
the pilot episode that the sound of the
force that Ezra heard sounds like a
whale
call a possible pgle out there and he
meets them here pgle will play an
important role in the final episode of
the series they show up in live action
in chapter 17 of the Mandalorian as well
as Ahsoka Perl consumed the Clauson 36
gas in the atmosphere to power their
ability to jump in hyperspace during
this mission to capture fuel from the
mining Guild Ezra and Kanan help these
Perle and Ezra forms a special bond with
these creatures that will pay off later
episode 16 homecoming so this is an
important Hera episode we visit the twe
like home of the riots system that first
appeared in flashback in the Clone Wars
season 1 episode Jedi crash we meet
hara's father Cham sendula a clone wars
hero with the nickname of the Liberator
of ryloth his first appearance was in
the Clone Wars episode Liberty on rith
father and daughter argue and we hear
tera's twe like accent come through here
I am part of something bigger Cham only
cares about the TW like resistance and
not the overall Rebel cause so he just
wants to bomb the Imperial carrier while
herrow wants to capture it so that the
rebels can use it but they do get to
blow up an Imperial Star Destroyer so
you know Cham does get his show of Force
episode 17 The Honorable ones so we
return to Geonosis that's the planet
from Attack of the Clones where they
learn that geonosian insectoid species
are all dead why well because Palatine
ordered the Gen side of the geonosians
to keep secret the construction of the
Death Star oh my God zeev and callus get
stranded together on a cave on a nearby
ice Moon they run into a bon zami
creature which gets his name from the
Zamboni this is an important episode for
Callis who admits to Zeb here that he
respects the lasat as Warriors and he
didn't agree with the Empire's decision
to exterminate them and that the bow
rifle he previously claimed to have
stolen from a deadli side Honor Guard
was actually given to him by by that
guard after he defeated him in an
honorable duel the two leave each other
with a mutual respect and they nearly
started kissing I would say but that
coldness that callus felt on this moon
was nothing compared to the coldness
that greeted him back on his Imperial
Star Destroyer our man's got thoughts
episode 18 shroud of Darkness okay so
all Jedi Temple or Sith Temple episodes
are must watches this one's no different
Kanan and Ezra battled the seventh
sister and fifth brother because Shopper
I guess forgot to pick them up they're
on usalon and Ezra and Kanan are saved
by the tities you remember these guys
seventh sister says such a handsome face
I don't go for crazy
anymore yeah it's a fun husband and wife
exchange between Geller and Prince
Ahsoka watches the recording of Anakin
I've made some adjustments to the
classic form four techniques so form
four also known as ataru is one of the
seven forms of lightsaber combat
practiced by both Jedi and Sith it's an
aggressive style that is fast-paced and
effective against single opponents the
weaker in prolonged combat and confined
spaces Anakin made some adjustments to
form four yeah because it fails him with
Dooku and this could actually explain
why Ahsoka uses two Sabers they returned
to the lothal Jedi Temple and Ezra asked
asks Ahsoka if she wants to open it but
she says she's no longer a Jedi but
because she is with them a different
deeper door on the temple opens inside
the three split up because we are in a
spiritual sequel to last season's path
of the Jedi and it's so good Kanan seeks
knowledge to defeat the inquisitors and
he is greeted in his vision by a
sentinel who is a Jedi Temple guard his
double-sided Sav tells us that it's
going to be a familiar face and yes it
is the udaan grand Inquisitor that was
voiced by Jason Isaac's it's a warning
that even great Jedi can still fall to
the will of the dark side so keep an eye
on Ezra Ezra meanwhile meets with Yoda
more than just his voice this time we
actually see Yoda as he communes with
Ezra from the swamps of daaba and he
shows Ezra a near shot for shot
Recreation the closing shots from Attack
of the Clones and he tells Ezra to find
malachor for Ahsoka Matt Lanter returns
as Anakin in this episode Ahsoka why did
you leave where were you when I needed
you do you know what I've
become yeah our girl cannot accept it
they escape an attack from the
inquisitors who are able to access this
Temple because they are former Jedi the
fifth brother says that the Jedi are
growing in their power power inv Vader
replies it will be their undoing true
true true okay episode 19 the Forgotten
joid in episode 20 The Mystery of the
chopper base they are both fun but
Filler episodes from Rebel season 2 I'd
say all you really need to know about
these is that in episode 20 they do run
into some CNA ice spiders like the ones
then Jaren and grou run into in Mando
season 2 okay here we go the two final
episodes episode 21 and episode 22
Twilight of The Apprentice part one and
part two so Ezra Ahsoka and Kanan go to
malachor which they say has always been
off limits to the Jedi and yeah no
Ahsoka says there's always a bit of
Truth in Legends I love this line so
many ways to read it truth in Legends
AKA expanded universe material truth in
Legends like ahsoka's experience in
mortise truth in legendary figures like
Maul and Truth in the Legends of the
Sith who for thousands of years were
really the dominant class of force
wielders malachor was actually first
alluded to back in 2004 in Star Wars
Knights of the Old Republic to the Sith
Lords it's where the dark side of the
force run strong approaching this planet
the trio see these large black
structures almost reminiscent of the
black monolith in 2001 Space odyy they
Jud out of the planet I got to say the
Sith design Style Just way better than
the Jedi style but the Sith Temple
appears like a pyramid just like the
holocron that Ezra will later obtain
Dave Fon has said in interviews that
they designed the Sith Temple to have
red glowing lines at the base to look
like veins because they want the Sith
temples and Jedi temples to feel like
sentient creatures in their own right
the three of them find this battlefield
where Sith and Jedi fought thousands of
years ago the Jedi hoping to stop a Sith
super weapon the Sith activated that
weapon and they turned all these living
beings into Pompei like Stone now this
actually inspired a kind of Sith drug
called ashes of malachor which allows
consumers to increase their ties to the
dark side and power at the cost of their
own mortality Maul is actually seen
inhaling some ashes of malachor in the
second issue of the comic book series
Darth Maul number two that was in 2017
Ezra picks up a broken cross guard
lightsaber with a green blade this
episode came out a few months after the
force awaken so this gave some
historical Credence to kylo Ren's blade
design the eighth brother a new
Inquisitor has been stalking them and it
keeps like fighting them and then being
like you better come chase me meanwhile
Ezra meets This Old Man calls himself
old Master this is actually Maul voiced
by Sam witor who of course voiced a
character in Clone Wars so awesome to
have him back when this episode came out
in 2016 the last time we had seen Maul
was in Clone Wars season 5 after his
seizure of Mandalore with the death
watch when he had the dark saber and he
was left tortured and taken by cyas who
at this point had replaced him with
Dooku and soon after that replacing
Dooku with Anakin now later Clone War
season 7 would show Maul's return to
Mandalore after his escape from cyas has
duel with Ahsoka and has escaped her in
order 66 so yeah right now our guy hates
the empire Ezra also uses an alas when
he talks to him names himself Jabba
which Maul can't help but laugh at
because he did meet the real Jabba the
Hut in Clone Wars episode Eminence when
Maul was head of the Shadow Collective
the Sith Temple requires two Jedi to
lift the stones together and two to
ascend the pyramid at any given time
reflecting of course the Sith rule of
two which Maul tries to use to isolate
himself with Ezra and manipulate Ezra's
pain your anger is a Wellspring you must
use it your passions give you strength
and through strength you gain power
power you have seen it you feel it you
must break your chains M has refined the
Sith holocron now this Sith holocron has
a small inscription that translates into
Latin in umbris poest EST or in the
shadows there is power Maul uses the
holocron to open doors a metaphor for
the doors to the dark side it can unlock
the three inquisitors unite and they
recognize Maul as the shadow which is
kind of their way saying Omar
coming Kanan Ezra and Ahsoka in Maul
versus the three inquisitors the
lightsaber dueling is so great in this
finale Maul for strokes and kills a
seventh sister Maul sees something
moving on the surface blocking out the
light from above it's a literal walking
Shadow definitely Vader approaching the
fifth brother goes down the eighth
brother Falls when his spinny blade
breaks but to his death probably we're
not exactly sure probably mul blinds
Kanan oh my God now this blindness is
actually part of the character design
from the start because in a now deleted
tweet Lucas Films Pablo adgo said that
Kanan and another blind Jedi character
Ram Kota from the Legends Canon were
both inspired by zichi who is a
prominent fictional character in
Japanese pop culture as reaches the top
of the pyramid and activates the
holocron it activates the presence which
is a disembodied intelligence taking the
form of pink and purple lightning it is
a female presenting voice played by
actress naika fman the presence is the
last remains of a female Sith who once
commanded the super weapon housed in the
Sith Temple this present says knowledge
is power Kanan reaches for a mask left
behind by one of these Jedi to battle
Maul literally there is truth and
legends here he uses this and the force
to defeat Maul the presence tells Ezra
that she's been waiting to unleash her
power at his command when Ezra refuses
she says that perhaps the other who
approaches will claim it but it's not
Maul it's Vader it's Vader versus Ezra
Vader says then you will die braver than
most but Ahsoka intervenes and Ahsoka
finally admits what she's been denying
all season and this exchange is so great
panic in the Skywalker was weak I
destroyed him then I will avenge his
death revenge is not the Jedi way I am
no Jedi yes Ahsoka transforms her guilt
for leaving the Jedi Order for leaving
Anakin into a new power to go further
than the Jedi Orthodoxy restraint would
allow her to go they start fighting
meanwhile blind Kanan arrives with
chopper adorably holding his hand the
master and Apprentice remove the
holocron together Ahsoka holds Vader
back Ahsoka slices Vader's helmet and
underneath oh my God we see Vader's face
now it includes an eyebrow the the
eyebrows supposed to be burned off but
they use this because they use Anakin's
3D animation model from the lightsaber
tutorial earlier and listen to this we
hear Ahsoka mixed in with Matt lanter's
voice and James Earl Jones
voice but as he transitions to then you
will die it is just one voice then you
will die the temple collapses as they
duel we don't learn until later how
Ahsoka got through her battle with Vader
but as Vader steps out of the ruins we
do see ahsoka's morai bird from the
mortise Arc in Clone Wars the final shot
of the season shows Ezra with the red
light of the Sith holocron reflected in
his eyes like that scar on his face his
brush with the dark side leaves a mark
season 3 let's get started episodes 1
and two steps into Shadow Parts one and
two it's 6 months after the season 2
finale and Ezra has a new haircut a new
green lightsaber and some unnatural
abilities unlocked by The Sith holocron
from malachor it continues to speak to
him through the presence that is the
spiritual essence of that Sith who
activated that super weapon on malachor
Ezra shows off that new haircut but also
turns to show a said scar this is his
archetypal unhealable wound from that
duel with a grand Inquisitor in season 1
symbolizing the festering dark side
presence in him they rescue Hondo anaka
and Ezra lets his ugot partner die and
then uses the force to walk an Imperial
Walker off a ledge yikes Sabine
repainted her armor this season so that
honor pdra now is ahsoka's morai bird
because as far as they know Ahsoka is
dead but it's this bird this episode
that leads Kanan to bendu Hera has a new
captain badge since she's been promoted
in the Phoenix Squadron Ezra speaks to
the holocron and its red glow is in his
eyes giving us this closeup matching the
closeup of thon's red chis eyes later
this episode Kanan confiscates the
holocron and gets summoned out to the
adelon wins by bendu voiced by Tom Baker
who's the fourth doctor and Doctor Who
David Tenon is now voicing huyang and
Ahsoka bendu is a force user who's
neither Jedi nor Sith actually the word
bendu comes from George lucas' original
treatment for Star Wars when Jedi
Knights were going to be called Jedi
bendu bendu teaches Kanan how to use the
force to see mostly by seeing past his
own fear so that he can walk past these
Crick spiders Kanan leaves the holocron
with bendu grand Admiral thraw enters
the chat voiced by Lars mikkelson who
will also be playing thraw in live
action he is the villain of these final
two seasons of rebels and of Ahsoka the
fact that he shows up here in the
premere of Rebel season 3 is a very very
big deal because this season was 2016
2017 when everyone was kind of confused
what Star Wars Legends were versus Star
Wars Canon and everyone was really
worried when Disney made that
recategorization because thraw is the
coolest character from Star Wars
expanded universe fiction from Timothy
Zan's air to the Empire novels in 1991
the fact that de Fon put him in Rebels
here shows us how important those
stories are to him and how we can never
forget them so thron wisely outsmarts
the rebels plot to steal W WIS I will
stop my operations here and pull the
rebels apart Peace by piece they'll be
the
architects of their own destruction and
in this transition we see his red eyes
watching over their every move as he
will throughout this entire season thraw
ends up being correct Ezra's Dark Side
influence bullishness caused them to
gain only a few wi wings at the cost of
their Phantom shuttle rip Phantom 1 on
episode three the holocrons of Fate Maul
captures most of the Rebel crew and
demands from Canaan and Ezra both the
Sith hologon and Jedi hologon Maul
recognizes to be as man Oran and says
that he once ruled her people referring
to the season 5 Arc and Clone Wars where
Maul took over the death watch and the
dark saber and took Mandalore bendu
tells Kanan and Ezra that if Jedi and
Sith holocrons are united they would
give the wielder too much Vision
something Kanan and Ezra learned the
value of by recovering the Sith holocron
from a cricet cave resisting Their Fear
and bendu warns once a secret is known
it cannot be unknown they return to
Maul's asteroid base which was last
seene in the son of death Meir comic run
and after Maul tries to blow Kanan out
of the airlock he does a forced
spacewalk like Leo will do in The Last
Jedi this episode released in October
2016 while the Last Jedi was still being
shot because Carrie Fisher was still
alive at this point Ezra and Maul join
the holoc CRS and for a moment Maul sees
his destination I see him twin Sons this
will eventually lead Maul to teine to
find kab be all right episode four the
Antilles extraction after losing a bunch
of awings the rebels get a transmission
from a new mystery fulm agent using
ahsoka's same symbol based on her to cre
a head markings saan infiltrates an
imperial Academy to recruit wedge and
voiced by Nathan Crest here in their
simulation the Tie fighters explode in a
way reminiscent to toys where the wings
pop off to simulate battle damage when
Bean wedge and others walk out to the
ties they use this catwalk and lower
into the cockpits and I love love love
this distinction that we see throughout
Star Wars you step up in the rebel ships
you lower down into these batlike
Imperial ties we actually saw this in
the eye of aldani episode of Andor as
well I think it looks so cool callus
actually ends up helping them escape to
repay Zeb for that icec moment that they
had M episode five haris Heroes so we
return to Roff where hara's father Cham
and Numa ride blurs these are the same
arvala 7 mounts that djaren rides in the
Mandalorian but they're actually first
seen in Ewoks the Battle of indoors Zeb
punches a scout trooper to steal his
helmet a helmet that Ezra will continue
to use and might show up in the
background of sabine's Home in Ahsoka
the culas have lost their family calicor
it honors all who have come before each
parent adds to the artwork to include
themselves in the Legacy h family
history is Living Art ah so an
appreciation of family history through
ART is a key theme from here forward as
Thon said this episode to defeat an
enemy you must know them not simply
their Battle Tactics but their history
philosophy art Sabine Ren is an artist
and that will play a big role in Ahsoka
also calori will show up in luthan's
shop and Andor and it's just kind of
crappy that he has one all right episode
six the last battle Rex takes them to a
battlefield from the Clone Wars era they
get captured by battle droids still on
the separatist programming led by
General Kanani this episode shows how
for Clone Wars veterans the war didn't
really end with any true resolution
ution as they were all misled by these
false motives and political games and
because this is the Clone Wars Vibe
episode this episode ends with the Clone
Wars animated series logo and theme over
the
credits all right episode seven Imperial
super Commandos saine Ren tries to lure
Mandalorian thin Ral and his protectors
to the rebel cause over a game of cubic
Cod this is from the 2007 novel Legacy
of the force sacrifice we see the
Phantom 2 in this episode is a new paint
job thanks to be with a timy on the side
they get captured by a group of Imperial
Mandalorian is led by gar Saxon voiced
by Ray Stevenson the late actor playing
balen skull in Ahsoka again we learned
that some mandalorians just support the
Empire and it kind of sucks Sabine and
Finn Escape but Sabine defeats gar in
hand-to-hand combat and Finn joins the
rebels a key partner from here Forward
episode 8 iron Squadron the specters
meet the iron Squadron led by Commander
st's nephew Mart voiced by Zachary
Gordon it's kind of a parallel team to
the ghost just younger and Dumber but
both teams have crabby astrx and love
space waffles guti terz is named after
Rebels retcon host Andy goodier and the
rebels Recon staff get shouted out
through the names throughout this
episode okay episode 9 the WIN kathu Job
Hondo onaka is back wearing a stupid
pirate hat with an even stupider as
Morgan hanging out with him returning
from the premiere with that stolen
Imperial landcraft they all head to the
planet wi cathu hoping to get some
proton bombs but Imperial DT Sentry
droids attack these are inspired by the
dark Troopers in the dark Forces game
which would also go on to inspire the
phase three dark Troopers in the
Mandalorian season 2 just everyone be
careful with these Hondo episodes
because it'll make you really hate that
load in area for smuggers run I'm sorry
I'm just not a huge fan of ano anako
he's kind of annoying all right episode
10 an inside man so back on lethal Ezra
and Kanan rejoined Ryder aadi Clancy
Brown's escaped prisoner who knew Ezra's
parents when they were in prison
together we saw him in season 2 and
aaditi serves as the governor of lothal
and Ahsoka family friend suar returns
from episode four of season 1 but he
dies when Thon makes him test a faulty
Speeder Bike the workers wear outfits
that kind of look like color swap narina
5 prisoner outfits from Andor Thon does
a whole Deep dive on all the imagery and
art that he can find in relation to the
ghost crew including depictions of loath
wolves as well as murals from Mandalore
depicting an ancient battle with a Jedi
we actually saw these in Clone Wars and
then this one with the woman crying is
clearly based on Pablo Picasso's guanica
also thraw as a Jedi Temple guard mask
on his desk like the one the grand
Inquisitor wore callus reveals himself
as fum and the rebels learn of thron's
plans to build the new TIE fighter the
tie Defender which comes with shields
it's designed based on the 1994 Tie
Fighter video game episode 11 visions
and voices this is a very important
episode to watch this was the mid-season
finale the last episode to come out
before Rogue One released in December
2016 Maul appears to Ezra in creepy
background apparitions just in these
flashes of lightning but there is no
lightning storm going on this is all
just in Ezra's mind he's freaking out so
they go to bendu where they find the
real Maul who takes Ezra to damir and
Canan sine followed closely as they walk
into damir Maul explains my family the
night sisters were killed masterful
witches they were we actually saw this
in Clone Wars a four-part Arc starting
with the season 4 episode 19 episode
Massacre the night sisters was a force
wielding cult including Maul's mother
talin who used sorcery to regant Maul
the ability to walk General Grievous
killed many of them off but we know of
one Survivor Marin in Jedi Fallen order
and now on Ahsoka Thon acolyte Morgan
eleth was revealed to be a night sister
so everything we can find on the night
sisters we need to pay attention to Maul
places his hand on this leg of a statue
and we see the other statues bisected at
the waist the same kind of injury that
Maul suffered from Kenobi actually
inside Maul's home in the mandoa
language he wrote Kenobi on the wall
he's got all kinds of interesting odds
and ends some Spears like the one used
by his brother saaj o press and a battle
droid he also has a painting of Duchess
Satine cre sister to Bo Katan and
Obi-Wan's former lover in Clone Wars
whom Maul executed with the dark saber
we also hear a pi version of satine's
theme as Ezra looks up at
[Music]
it and it kind of looks like Maul has
defaced this portrait just out of hatred
of Kobi but the most important object
here is the dark saber Maul previously
wielded it in season five of Clone
Moores and here on Rebels it re-enters
the Star Wars timeline yes I've talked
about the dark saber a lot and all my
breakdowns of the Mandalorian and the
book of Boba Fett but this is where it
re-enters the chat Maul and Ezra drink a
nightsister potion to merge their minds
to gain the knowledge that the other has
from their Sith Jedi holocron crossover
moment and Maul realizes that Kenobi is
on Tatooine but they awaken the spirits
of the night sisters hey
I the spirits of the night sisters
Sabine and Canan get possessed by these
Spirits they're trapped in the temple
and Maul leaves but possessed Sabine has
picked up the dark saber and to me that
is a critical moment because I believe
the dark saber is cursed it should have
stayed in here Sabine only picked it up
because evil nightsister sorcery
compelled her to do so the night sisters
are behind a lot of this stuff Ezra uses
his green lightsaber and the dark saber
to destroy the altar banishing the
nightsister ghosts but in characters
like Morgan elth the nightsister Legacy
lives on episode 12 and 13 The Ghost of
Geonosis part 1 and two Rebel extremist
s Guerrera returns now voiced by Forest
Whitaker who had just had a big moment
as s Guerrera in Rogue one this is the
era of saw that we actually saw in the
flashback of Rogue one when he rescued
Jen erso when he was still bald saw has
gone missing on the planet of Geonosis
that you remember from Attack of the
Clones and remember the geonosians had
been mostly eradicated by the Empire to
keep secret the Death Star construction
so saw interrogates a surviving geosan
named click clack who draws two circles
in the dirt indicating the Death Star
but everyone else is like what's that
Rex explains that Saw's sister Stila
Guerrera died from a geonosian built
gunship and we saw Stila in Clone Wars
and her death would be a rallying Cry
For The andonian Click clock's Hideout
also has a queen egg that would give the
geonosians a chance to repopulate he
also has a cloer helmet the arm and head
of a battle Droid and part of a
destroyer droid the rebels Tred to
retrieve gas canisters to prove the
Empire's war crimes but they end up
losing them in their escape and borana
says the S can't really do anything
about it ah poor geonosians all right
episode 14 Warhead it's a Zeb episode
Thon unleashes Imperial infiltrator
droids across the Galaxy in one lands at
Chopper base on adalon cannibalizing
other droids to repair itself and
preparing to transmit info back to the
Empire hitting a self-destruct protocol
but they let it transmit and then delay
the explosion for when he gets back to
its spaceship yet Thon from this is able
to use this to narrow down his search
Episode by episode he's getting closer
and closer to finding out where the
rebels are all right episode 15 Trials
of the dark saber this is an episode I
brought up back in my Mandalorian
breakdowns and it's super important to
understand the Mandalorian themes Fen
raal gives us the history of the dark
saber Legend tells that it was created
over a thousand years ago by tar vizla
the first Mandalorian ever inducted into
the Jedi Order after his passing the
Jedi kept the Sab in their Temple that
was until members of house vizla snuck
in and liberate ah so we get this
ancient history of the mandalorians and
Jedi at war with each other in s's bunk
we see a rough trap of the mural that
she'll later paint on L fall Chopper we
find out is uh got the hots for
her Kanan and Ezra Tak Sabine out on a
sword dueling session Ezra First shows
her ready position which Sabine
demonstrates while fighting chinatti in
Ahsoka episode 1 Kanan shed some light
on sabine's struggles with the force the
force resides in all living things but
you have to be open to it Sabine is
blocked her mind is conflicted yes
huyang and Ahsoka similarly dismisses
sabine's Force ability but during this
training morai birds still flap down to
watch thin raal gives Sabine Mandalorian
van braces that she will continue to
wear in Ahsoka she uses these to get the
upper hand but Canan shuts her down for
cheating saying the Jedi won the war
with the mandalorians and it wasn't
through shortcuts it was through
discipline now while Dave Fon was
crafting the Kanan jarett's character it
was really important to him to craft him
as an incomplete Mentor in the style of
gandal and the Lord of the Rings that
he's just too far beyond his ability to
communicate his wisdom to the younger
padawans so he's not a perfect teacher
and he often makes mistakes and learns
lessons himself a little too late so
Kanan finally comes around and just lets
saine train with the actual dark saber
it's heavier than I thought energy
constantly flows through the crystal
you're not fighting with a simple blade
as much as you are directing a current
of power your thoughts your actions they
become energy and as Sabine duels that
blade gets lighter and lighter for her a
contrast to djaren the Mandalorian who
always struggles to lift that dark saber
and we get this amazing emotional moment
from Sabine as she duel Kanan everything
I did was for family for Mandalore I
built weapons weapons terrible weapons
but the Empire used them on Mandalore on
friends on famili I helped enslave my
people please please please keep all of
this in mind as you watch Sabine in
Ahsoka because this is where she is
coming from and this moment always just
wrecks me the Empire wanted to destroy
worlds and they
did they destroyed
mine so with Sabine and Ahsoka in the
Ahsoka series it's not a master
Apprentice relationship Sabine just
wants a s and we see how messed up
saine's family is in episode 16 Legacy
of Mandalore they head to cronis a Snowy
Mountain setting that I think is a
prettiest location in Star Wars they're
attacked by super Commandos led by
saine's Brother Tristan they meet her
mother ctis Ursa who also appears in the
final season of Clone Wars by the way
and we learned that house Ren is loyal
to the Empire with gar Saxon considered
the emperor's hand Ursa gives Saxon the
dark saer in a trade for her daughter
but Saxon doesn't hold up his end of the
bargain and we end up in this incredible
duel between Saxon with the dark saber
and Zine with Ezra's lightsaber setting
up Sabine to later use this green blade
throughout Ahsoka Sabine disarms Saxon
of the dark saber but Saxon didn't
technically win it in combat so the
curse of none of these mandalorians
earning the dark saer lives on so Bean
for now decides to stay behind on cronis
all right episode 17 through Imperial
eyes which is how this episode opens
Through The Eyes of our secret fulm spy
callus Ezra tries to get him to defect
and Thon arrives on his Star Destroyer
the Chimera that was a name of his ship
from his original novels he trains in a
sexy sexy vest against a DT centy Droid
and shut word is Ruck which is the name
of a male nree warrior who first
protected then assassinated Thon in
those books this is such a great thraw
episode and I highly recommend it thon's
hallway is actually filled with Easter
eggs we see the Holy Grail from Indiana
Jones of the Last Crusade Lucas film
loves to do this just see Andor it's
kind of weird we see Clone Commander
greze helmet from Revenge of the Sith
this is one of the guys Yoda beheaded on
kashik during Order 66 we see a bust of
an Abid NATO that's El AES species
created for the force awakens film and
then a digital version of Ralph mccc's
concept art that Rebels used as a
painting n laal and then on the back
wall is salir these are the lizard-like
creatures from Timothy zon's air of the
Empire novels which were immune to the
force they admitted these anti-force
Bubbles and of course we see that thron
kept the calori that he stole from the
culla family because for Thon it is all
about the art wolf uren from the ISB
appears you remember him he was the
white uniformed officer in tarkin's
meeting room on the Death Star in a new
hope we end this episode with Thon
knowing that callus is a traitor but he
lets it slide for now another important
thing about Thon our man is p all right
episode 18 secret cargo secret cargo
revealed to be Senator Mon mothma
another figure who returns in Ahsoka
during the New Republic era but this
episode is important for her Andor
period and here she speaks out against
the emperor for the Gorman Massacre
she's voiced by geneveve O'Reilly I Nam
the emperor himself for ordering the
brutal attacks on the people of Gorman
our self-appointed emperor is little
more than a lying executioner mothma is
now out of the Senate on the run and
they have to fight off thron's tie
Defenders and the archon nebula which
reminds me of of furiosa losing a Morton
Joe's men during the sandstorm and Fury
Road it looks really cool mothma escapes
to danine where she sends out a message
to inspire the rebel cause for too long
I've watched the heavy hand of the
Empire strangle our liberties despite
Imperial threats despite the emperor
himself I have no fear as I take new
action we see Bale Orana and general Jan
doana and we also see the loal bar from
season 1's Empire day so paired with
Ezra's big broadcast in season 1 this is
the next important mass media call to
action for the Rebel Alliance all right
episode 19 double agent Droid it's a
chopper episode Chopper gets hijacked by
an imperial agent the controller there
is a fun moment in this episode where
the Spy ship control room is inspired by
George Lucas's first feature THX 11138 a
movie that gets referenced all the time
but you know what watch it it's
groundbreaking but also not that good
all right episode 20 twin Suns
definitely one to watch this episode
opens with the twin Suns of Tatooine and
Maul returning here after first seeing
Kenobi in Phantom Menace wanders the
desert Delirious see him in my mind's
eye
[Music]
Kenobi
Kenobi and you just got to see the
behind the-scenes footage of sand wh
we're recording this in the ADR booth in
my mind's
eye
Kenobi
Kenobi Ezra and Chopper sneak off to
Tatooine to save Obi-Wan Kenobi but Ezra
sees how coarse and rough and irritating
the sand is he doesn't really need to be
in this episode he does get saved once
by Maul and again by Kenobi and Kenobi
tells Ezra that obiwan Kenobi isn't the
answer to defeating the Sith as far as
he knows this is just a manipulation by
Maul Kenobi at first has no intention of
fighting Maul until Maul forces his hand
oh you have a purpose here perhaps you
are protecting something
no
protecting
someone and this leads to one of the
shortest but best Duss in all of Star
Wars and it's all in the buildup
[Music]
[Applause]
now Sam whitw loves to break this down
in interviews but basically Kenobi
starts in the Clone Wars era you and
McGregor pose with the two fingers and
then he realizes no mistakes were made
during that era so then he shifts to the
two-handed Alec Guinness ready position
from A New Hope but then seeing the
confidence in Maul's eyes he decides to
take another breath and he shifts to the
Qui-Gon gin pose batter up trying to
bait Maul into trying the same move that
he used on Qui-Gon Maul takes his bait
he tries to do the same kind of flourish
and stab but Kenobi is ready for him and
recognizing that he has freed his old
foe from this Vengeance he cradles him
tell me is it the chosen one he
is he will avenge
us chills Maul and Obi-Wan are finally
United and there sense of betrayal from
what the emperor did to them and Maul
dies with confidence that there exists
somewhere a child who will restore
balance to the force this episode ends
with Obi-Wan looking out over the large
Homestead as ant Buu calls now this
would be a few years after obiwan
Kenobi's interactions with Owen and Buu
in the obiwan Kenobi series on Disney
plus and Luke I think would actually be
around Ezra's age here they actually use
one of Ezra's character models for the
animation of Luke running okay onto the
two-part finale episodes 21 and 22 Zero
Hour Parts 1 and two the rebels plan
their attack on the Imperial Factory on
the fall but Thon catches callus giving
a fuler message and Thon triangulates
the vectors of this message to find the
planet such as a system which does not
appear on Imperial charts but is
represented in the art of the ancient
people of this sector I believe they
called this atalon the ancient people of
this sector this could connect with the
ancient star map that Morgan elth is
using on Ahsoka to find her way to thraw
which I have theorized could be based on
the ancient ricot Empire seen in the
nights of the Old Republic games this
could explain why the home of bendu is a
place older than what is known to the
Jedi or the Sith and I just love that
all season long we have had this Arc for
Thon to study each puzzle piece of art
and history and finally by patiently
allowing callus to do his thing he got
the answer he needed this is the clever
villain Star Wars needs more of and it's
the reason we're so excited to see thraw
in live action please don't mess this up
Asoka in this episode there is an
incredible space battle the Imperial
interdictor comes back pulling out any
escaping ships back out of hyperspace
but Commander Sato sacrifices himself
Thon only loses his position seod
because Constantine defies his order so
that he can get Glory really thraw
doesn't make any mistakes this episode
that's what makes him so scary Kanan
rallies bendu to join the fight calling
him a coward Perhaps it is the will of
the force that the Jedi and all your
kind
perish and I serve the will of the
thce you know what he ain't wrong th
bombard guards the chopper base
protected by Rex and zeb's shield at
first but thraw ceases fire meanwhile
Hera calls Kanan now please come home
love yeah as a series goes on we do
start to get more and more affectionate
moments between these two Ezra heads to
cronis to recruit saine and we see
Tristan In This Moment has an orange
barking on his shoulder pauldron so
Sabina has clearly started decorating
her brother's armor she's kind of like
Harold with a purple crayon she's great
so Thon leads with a ground Invasion now
wearing it goofy ground Invasion hat and
he lands with some Imperial death
Troopers we actually saw these Troopers
with krennic and Rogue one so Thon
surrounds them but bendu mu fases in the
sky with a lightning storm and if you
look closely as they all Escape he takes
out some at-ats at ATS Walkers whatever
you want to call him but also takes out
some y wings so bendu was not kidding
about not picking a side here and he
really just wants these waren kids off
his damn lawn Ezra in sabine's group
disables The interdictor and callus gets
away in an escape pod the rebels Escape
right past Governor price not a good
look for her they all regroup on Yavin 4
this is the final episode to take place
in the year 2 BBY meaning with season 4
we will be entering the final year
before the Battle of Y but I will leave
you here this is perhaps the most
cryptic moment of the season and a super
important moment between bedu and Thon
you cannot
see but I
can what what do you
see I see your defeat like many arms
surrounding you in a cold
Embrace now we could read this as what
happens in the season 4 finale Ron is
caught in the cold embrace the many arms
of the pgle zipping him off in a
hyperspace but was that truly his defeat
because Thon is still alive in Ahsoka
but it's important to note that bendu
does not say death here he says defeat
still thon's death whenever it comes
hopefully sometime Beyond Ahsoka because
I don't want him to die in the series
his death his inevitable death May
Circle back to this premonition to show
thraw dying surrounded by some different
arms maybe his acolytes all dogpiling on
him and strangling him thon's survival
from the purgo may give him a false
confidence that he thinks he already
cheated death according to what bendu
predicted making the guy think he's
Immortal you know what Pride goeth
before the fall okay here we go episodes
1 and two Heroes of Mandalore on the
plan of Mandalore Sabine leads her clan
Ren on a rescue mission for her father
Empire loyal mandalorians are led by
Tyber Saxon brother dargar Saxon so this
final season opens with the rebels
retaking one of their home worlds
Mandalore and it ends with a sort of
liberation of lothal Ezra's home making
this whole season a full homecoming
Sabine has a new jetpack with purple
wings and still carries the dark saber
after season 3 episode 11 visions of
voices saw her possessed by a
nightsister ghost on damir and take it
from Maul's Temple and Kanan trained her
with this saber in Trials of the dark
saber but it does remain a cursed
artifact that she doesn't really want
Sabine is saved by boaton cre Katie sack
off is returning from Clone Wars but she
also doesn't want the dark saber
initially Ezra's uncertain jetpack
flight this episode is modeled on art
for The Rocketeer directed by Joe
Johnston who did the original jetpack
designs for Boba fet these Rebels
learned that war with the Empire has
erased their want for leadership even
Once Upon a Time these planes were
covered with grass and it never grew
back never had a chance to too this is
what continuous War has done to my home
Mandalore was initially scorched after
an ancient war with the Jedi but further
Fusion bombs by m Gideon that will take
place after this will turn this surface
into Rocky glass we'll see this in the
Mandalorian season 3 yet vegetation will
begin to grow in caves and a mythosaur
will appear in the Living Waters but
again this is set before those bombings
happen the Mandalorian capital city of
sundari is still standing its doed
appearance actually came from the design
development for Clone Wars George Lucas
suggested to use a track ball Mouse as a
starting point Andrew voices Captain
hark after being the original voice of
sag Guerrera in Clone Wars s Guerrera in
this show is voiced by for stiger from
Rogue one their attack on the transport
was inspired by the truck Chase and
Raiders of the Lost AR and the tank
Chase in Last Crusade Sabine uses purple
paint to Blind the driver the power of
Art in action later on this season
they'll use spray paint to get the upper
hand on Rook the Assassin and this
artistic flare is something that Sabine
actually gets from her father or your
design aesthetic is still derivative of
the pre-ex Masters tojan was an
influence obviously but I I made it my
own Ursa and Tristan's group gets wiped
out by a laser that vaporizes wearers of
bescar armor something that Sabine we
learned designed during her time with
the Empire they call this weapon The
Duchess after botan's sister Duchess
Satine which just feels doubly cruel for
the Mandalorian people even Thon seems
uncertain about conquering Mandalorian
with such cruelty showing that he
understands the importance of respecting
ancestral heritage this is the first
time the Mandalorian armor is referred
to as bescar in Canon it was first
mentioned in Star Wars repu commando
hard contact the original idea for the
episode actually was to have Sabine KN
her mandalorians with the dark saber
leaving scorches on their armor so
really the dark saer for her is more of
a paintbrush and it is a weapon Sabine
hands off the dark saber to bokatan cre
in this episode and bokatan uses it to
unite all the Mandalorian factions I
accept this sword for my sister for my
clan and for all of
Mandalore but Sabine says that the saber
came to her so that she could pass it to
Baton and I look at that the way
diseases work viruses curses these
things exist so that the host can
transmit them as far as possible all
right episodes three and four in the
name of rebellion we see the Yavin four
base in the massassi temple which of
course was first seen in Matt paintings
in the original 1977 Star Wars this is
Chopper's first time here ahead of his
liveaction cameo in Rogue one when the
ghost crew will actually join the Battle
of scariff s Guerrera appears the rebel
extremist matching his appearance in
Rogue one when his gray hair has grown
in yet he still has his legs these
episodes so those injuries plus the
breathing apparatus he'll need to those
happen after this his massive Holo
projection literally talks down to mon
mothma but she stands her ground and
snaps if we degrade ourselves to the
Empire's level what will we become this
line mirrors what s Guerrero will tell
Jen erso in Rogue one what will you
become saws youu Wing arrives to help it
is the same black and white partisan
markings that we see it have on jeda and
Rogue one they find a group of Engineers
from corant being shipped to jeta and a
giant Kyper Crystal referring to the
collaborators of gayen Oro there were
shipped from corant to U in Rogue one
and the Crystal being what the Empire
wanted to use to power the Death Star
super laser Ezra senses this at first by
hearing the crystal as a song which I
believe links his force abilities with
the song of the pergal hyperspace whales
the crystal explodes releasing a green
shock wave evoking the detonation of the
Star Wars super laser like we saw kyber
crystals exploding in season 1 episode 6
all right episode 5 the occupation
Sabine has now updated her look with
darker hair that she keeps for the rest
of the season until the epilog mon MAA
calls a planet lool and I just really
appreciate how filon does this even
though it's lothal just recalling the
planet's pronunciation from the series
pilot episode and kind of like Mix end
up calling at-ats at ATS and Walkers he
just kind of makes room for everyone's
pronunciation and shuts down those
Gatekeepers like to um actually people
in the comments that said pgle is
singular and plural you don't say purgal
that's just basic human decency okay
Vago returns getting traded some puffer
pigs returning from season 1 with some
piglet versions these designs were made
for the season 1 Lando episode but scrap
from that episode they come back here
they're a lot of fun lothal's ecology we
learn has been scorched its grasslands
have been wiped out echoing sabine's
lament over mandalore's ecological
transformation thank God we do see a
straight look at in an alley also some
wanted posters of the specters lining
the walls using their photos from their
season 1 and two appearances this is
when they were outed at the Old Joe's
Bar from Empire day the bartender is now
Imperial pilot Veen Rutter returning
from season 1 when he was given the
parade armors the hollow net screen
ticker in orish reads farewell and then
21 Chloe dirkes elicious and Sammy have
left the building must be some kind of
in joke with the animators ja Kel
returns calling Ezra Oleg which was the
name of the loyal Imperial Cadet who
nearly spoiled Ezra's undercover mission
in the breaking ranks episode ja Kel now
on Ahsoka serves as a senator on lothal
with Governor riter aadi episode 6
Flight of the defender three adorable
loath cats hop up next to Ezra and he
cannot help but smile at these
celestials gifts from mortis giving them
well deserve scratchy scratches now the
sound of the cats are actually
recordings from sound designer David
accord's cat text they see the new tie
Defender which was given a new color
scheme a reshaped rear engine a
hyperdrive unit and the wings now
actually pop off in the style of the ker
Tie Fighter toys Thon arrives to inspect
these and Ezra sees on the hill his
first loath wolf and there's an animated
Dolly zoom on Ezra in this moment
because these are extremely important we
actually saw depictions of loath wolves
in the loal Jedi Temple art in season 1
and two and Ezra says while they haven't
been seen in 100 years here they are
Ezra follows a white loath cat to safety
kind of like the white rabbit from
Alison land as Ezra's Journey with the
animals of loal does take him through a
Looking Glass a larger loath wolf greets
Ezra and takes him to safety I don't
understand why did you help
us Doom now first we think it's Doom D
oom but it's actually Doom d m as in
Caleb Doom Kanan jerus is original name
but both homophones right now leave us
with an ominous feeling episode 7
Kindred Thon dispatches an assassin
named Rook you'll remember the word Ruck
as the shutdown command for thron's
Droids in season 3 but the character of
Ruck was thron's bodyguard in Timothy
Zan's 1991 air to the Empire who
eventually turned on Thon and
assassinated him but not here now
Timothy zon wanted Ru species to be
called Sith to justify Darth Vader's
title of Lord of the Sith but later
Lucas film would establish the Sith as a
dark side cult opposed to the Jedi so
instead he's called a noi and the Noe
skull does sort of resemble the helmet
of Darth Vader here he's voiced by
longtime Lucas film actor Warwick Davis
Lo wolves lead them into caves and sine
CE the cave drawings of the Lo wolves as
constellations like the path to peridia
closing credits and Ahsoka which I
translated every single Rune in in
another video definitely go watch that
it's going to be one of the most useful
videos you can watch for Ahsoka the Lo
wolves then lead them in this forc
imbued path now we'll see more of this
realm later but remember back in season
2 episode 1 Minister Tua before her
death hinted at a real reason the empire
was interested in loal and this is it
folks but even more interestingly cave
paintings depict Jedi descending from
space one of these is a tall pointy head
likely kiad Mundi we also see Yoda with
his lightsaber on his Hilt not just the
Yoda species this is a Jedi Yoda and
then a third figure a human beside them
I assume this is Mace Wu and then a Jedi
child hovers over them so the Assumption
since then has been that this depicts
these three Jedi bringing a young Caleb
Doom to the lothal Jedi Temple as a
youngl and that is how he got the name
Doom because these cave drawings are
thousands of years old this would have
been something that was predicted
thousands of years prior the whole idea
of this episode is Kanan and Ezra are
Kindred through the force connected to
lothal through the threads of Fate
episode8 crawler common deers mining
Guild or crawlers burn up the loal
grasslands now these designs came from
the world Devastators these were flying
automated factories from 1991 Legends
comic series dark Empire Captain Siver
listens to the same music that Zeb
listens to back in the season 2 episode
The Mystery of Chopper base the slave
master that Zeb fights is named prach a
notu pat Roach The Stunt actor who
fought Indiana Jones in the first three
Indie movies though his scene was
removed from Last Crusade and then after
decoding the schematics to the tie
Defender Elite Hera pushes the rebels to
strike their Imperial Factory on loal
big mistake episode 9 Rebel assault Mart
Matten from the iron Squadron episode
returns as a pilot in hara's group and
on his helmet is Sammy and ores these
x-wings you'll notice are painted green
but they're not part of the green
Squadron they're just part of Harris's
Phoenix Squadron here but other than a
more recent appearance of an X-Wing in
Andor season 1 this I think would be the
earliest chronological appearance of
x-wings ahead of their use in the Battle
of Scarff in Rogue one and the Battle of
Yavin in A New Hope their build is
slightly tweaked to match the
proportions of the 1978 toy but the tie
Defender Elites just wipe out these
x-wings had this tie Defender program
been expanded there would just be no way
the rebels would have made it through
the Death Star Trench Run and the Empire
would not have lost the Galactic Civil
War episode 10 Jedi Knight opens with
price torturing Hera and Thon brings
back in Hera's calori and singles out a
single beat for a brother who died in
the past as Ezra senses from the Tower
of fora we see some Loth bats which flew
to the city from the Empire's ecological
dest destruction so they kind of made a
mistake there because it creates an
opening for the rebels to sneak in with
these gliders Kanan uses a knife to cut
his hair a ritual that we see Sabine ren
do in Ahsoka Tarkin tells Thon your tie
Defender program is at risk Oren krennic
has been quite persuasive about
diverting the funding to his own project
Stardust now of course he's referring to
krennic's death star project so again
it's the Quick Fix of the Death Star
that defunded the harder to eradicate
offensive Hardware that the Empire would
have been Invincible with the tied to
Enders I also like this detail because
it's clear that Tarkin initially was
super skeptical of project Stardust but
as soon as it was effective he took all
the credit for it away from krennic
Harris says I have to tell you
something
I I hate your hair now we've already
seen them kiss so yeah I don't think she
just wants to say I love you I think
another calori bead is on the way here
they fly down to pick up Kanan and Hera
but price uses a walker to fire on the
fuel pot and Kanan uses the force to
repel the Flames his other hand to push
push back Hera to the ship no words are
exchanged here just observe and
[Music]
weep interesting how kanan's Force
projection is tinted blue like his
lightsaber and it's pretty rare to see a
manipulation of heat and energy and
chemical reactions like this it's not
common to see this in Star Wars kylo Ren
did suspend a blaster bolt in the force
awakens and of course grou pulled off a
very similar move in the Mandalorian
season 3 finale we are left this episode
in heartbreak the closing title is
rendered in Bleak charred Ash episode 11
Doom as Hera Moren Chopper holds her
hand just like he did to Kanan when
Kanan was first Blinded in the season 2
finale Ezra meets the Doom wolf which
has on its head the same symbol that
Kanan had on his shoulder armor in the
credits of the episode Dave Fon credited
the voice of the Doom wolf as played by
quote the force but it does kind of
sound like Freddy Prince Jr as the wolf
is kind of an embodiment of the force
through kanan's Essence go
past
redeem future the Wolves give Ezra this
stone with three hands one closed one
fir an open another relaxed and open
this Stone will show up actually in
Luther and riel's Shop in Andor and we
will see the Stone's importance in
episode 12 wolves and aore they ride a
pack of loath wolves to the loal Jedi
Temple and as they descend into the Tall
Grass Hera experiences some flashbacks
to Major Kan and Jared's moments from
throughout the series with lines from
Spark Rebellion path of the Jedi vision
of Hope fire across the Galaxy and Siege
of lothal they also use a recording of
thraw from the season 3 finale zero hour
to distract the Scout Troopers and steal
their helmets helmets that we might see
in the back of sabine's room in Ahsoka
we meet Varys Heiden Voice by Malcolm
McDow an adviser to Palpatine and a
scholar of the Jedi and Sith lore a part
originally meant to be served by vanon
Vader's assistant in Rogue one but here
heyen speaks with Palpatine who of
course is voiced by Ian mcdad symbols
and iconography are reminiscent of a
report I discovered in the Jedi
archives the mortis Gods woo okay the
mortis Gods I think we might have do a
whole other video just on the mortise
Arc but I'm going to give you quick
recap here the mortis gods are from the
Clone Wars ARC in season 3 episodes 15
16 and 17 they are the Father the
daughter and the son and yes they are
essentially the Holy Trinity of the Star
Wars Universe technically they are
considered celestials in Star Wars lore
yes there are celestials in Marvel but
there are also celestials in Star Wars
the sun represents the dark side of the
force the daughter represents the light
side of the force and the father
represents the balance between so in
this Ark obiwan Ahsoka and Anakin end up
in the realm of mortis and they find
these three figures the father actually
tells Anakin to stay with them in mortis
because he is the chosen one the son
takes Ahsoka captive to try to force
Anakin to join him in overpowering the
father and the daughter a lot of
goes down but when the son is about to
kill the Father the daughter sacrifices
herself to save the father and transfers
her life force to Ahsoka and this
connection is represented from here
forward word in the form of a socus bird
morai next Sun shows Anakin future
visions of himself as Vader and Anakin
freaked out about what might come next
decides to join the son briefly but the
father ends up erasing Anakin's memory
and kills himself with a sword to take
his son's power away allowing Anakin to
kill the sun it is crazy just watch
these three episodes you'll see what I
mean so Ezra and Sabine recognized the
three hands from the stone the fist for
the sun firm hand for the father and a
relaxed hand for the daughter Sabine
makes the connection of the three hands
just as she makes a connection with the
three faces of the night sister star map
in Ahsoka here she says the painting on
the temple is like a star map but none
that I'm familiar with those lines are
like paths and the Rings are planets or
or doorways the lines are like paths and
the Rings are planets or doorways we see
the same thing in the path to peridia
starm map in Ahsoka especially in the
closing credits the golden line
represents the path and the golden rings
represent planets again watch that video
where I break down all the runes and
what what all those planets mean Ezra
places his hand on the relaxed daughter
hand and the ring lights up and the
doorway reconfigures and Ezra follows
the loath wolves as they walk in a ring
forming a portal bringing us to episode
13 a world Between Worlds I'm telling
you it is the most important episode of
this series throughout this episode we
hear famous lines from Star Wars history
first Yoda this is from Attack of the
Clones truly wonderful the mind of child
is Yoda speaking to Obi-Wan in the Jedi
Temple when they were looking for Camino
on the star M truly wonderful the mind
of a child is I think we'd lead with
this because Yoda is respecting how
wonderful Ezra's young mind is for
discovering this next Obi-Wan and
Qui-Gon from Clone Wars part of the
mortise Arc overlords what is this place
conduit through which the entire force
of the universe flows what is this place
unlike any other a conduit through which
the entire force of the universe flows
ah what Quon described then is what we
are seeing now next Yoda in Empire
Strikes Back which happens after this
luminous being not this
crude luminous being not this crude
matter he's speaking to Luke In This
Moment a way of saying we are beings
made of light and the force we are not
just blood bone and muscle next Ahsoka
in season two of rebels you think you
understand the force you find out how
little you actually know just when you
think you understand the force you find
out how little you actually know spoken
to Ezra and now we are seeing that the
force is far more complex than any of us
thought next Yoda in the Sith train
yourself to let go of everything you
fear to lose train yourself to let go of
everything you fear to lose now very
important advice for Ezra in this realm
next Obi-Wan in the season 3 episode
twin Suns what you need you already have
unfortunately seem to be letting it all
go what you need you already have
unfortunately you seem to be letting it
all go which old Ben said to Ezra and
also seems to respond to Yoda's previous
line next Canaan and Rebels I won't let
him lose his way like I I won't let him
lose his way not like I did showing how
kanan's guidance is still with Ezra even
now okay so Ezra walks through the world
Between Worlds this is a realm in which
the force connects all of time and space
next we hear a very important line the
force is what gives the Jedi power it's
an energy field created by all living
things it surrounds us and penetrates us
it binds the Galaxy together this is of
course Alec Guinness Obi-Wan and A New
Hope a conversation with Luke that has
not happened yet the force is what gives
the Jedi is power it's an energy field
created by all living things it
surrounds us and penetrates us it binds
the Galaxy together now more come a bit
later they're all kind of mixed
together Master
Yoda
Obi-Wan where are
you so you heard three there there was
Yoda in Revenge of the Sith Rejoice for
those around you who transform into the
force there was Ms Canada to Ray in the
force awakens way in the future from now
I see your eyes you already know the
truth and cheered mway in Rogue one the
Force is with me and I am with the force
and then right after this we actually
hear JY erso from Rogue one time to
fight is the time to fight is now and
then the voice of kylo Ren from the
force awakens show show me inter first
with Ry whispering in the force awakens
see each other again we'll see each
other again and then some words from the
father to Anakin in the mortise episode
of overlords and now and now you see who
you truly are then po damaran Whispering
from the force awakens intimidated the
resistance will not be intimidated by
you then the dying words of the daughter
an altar of mortise is it is his nature
then mazada again for the force
awakens is not behind the belonging you
seek is not behind you and then Leia in
a new hope this is our most desperate
hour this is our most desperate hour
then Yoda and Revenge of the Sith greed
that is the shadow of greed that is and
then Leia finishing her line from A New
Hope help me obiwan Kenobi you're my
only help me Obi-Wan Kenobi you're my
only hope and then Anakin and Clone War
is telling Ahsoka Never Would Have Made
It as Obi-Wan's pan you never would have
made it as Obi-Wan's Padawan so Ezra
finds the morai bird taking Ezra to a
portal Through Time back to ahsoka's
duel with Vader on malachor in the rebel
season 2 finale we never saw exactly how
that duel ended and now we see what
happened Vader is just about to kill her
but Ezra pulls her out of time Ezra up
until this moment had thought Ahsoka was
dead so he thought in this moment he
changed history to save her not
realizing that she was always alive so
he mistakenly runs away from Ahsoka to
try to find Kanan and we actually hear
some voices from Kanan like here I'm
about to let everyone in on the secret
this was the moment he revealed himself
as a Jedi in the season one early
episodes I'm about to let everyone in on
the secret then a line overheard by Ezra
from Kanan toara in the season 2
premiere I survived one war I'm not
ready for I survived one war I'm not
ready for another one then Kanan in the
season 3 episode about Rex's Clone Wars
memories battles leave scores some you
can't see battles leave scars some you
can't see and I love that we hear this
line here because battles leaving scars
is evidence that those battles happen
that you can't change history to erase
the scar you have to keep the scar with
you and sometimes you can't see it it's
just something you have to carry with
you that is the point of life experience
we cannot erase or evade or sidestep
that life experience but as we're return
to the moment of kanan's death on the
Fuel Depot and Ahsoka says that Canan
needed to die so that the others could
live then the emperor calls out to them
is a Brier and the
sh Mine At Last now this blue flame on
the pedestal appeared in Clone War
season 6 when Yoda went to moraband and
the emperor tried to corrupt his mind
through his connection with Count Dooku
it's just super creepy that the emperor
can see through time this way using a
Sith sorcery the emperor says me the way
help me the way Ian mcdad says help me
recalls how he said it to Anakin after
mace Wu scarred him in Revenge of the
Sith help help me so Ahsoka ends up
going back through her portal to the
aftermath of her duel with Vader in the
season 2 finale when she limped out of
that Sith temple on malachor with morai
this is actually the episode we learned
mori's name and in Greek mythology the
morai spelled differently were the name
of the three Fates Ezra presses his hand
against the Fist of the Sun and we hear
some of his words from the morar and
Clone Wars and Ezra passes out and the
temple collapses now filon has said that
he doesn't think of the world Between
Worlds as time travel that instead it's
about gaining knowledge of the future
and as the Doom wolf says restore the
past redeem the future so again Ezra has
already changed the past that is how
Ahsoka was already alive so in a sense
he just kind of closed the loop He
restored the past and by learning to
move on from Kanan jer's death he has
redeemed the future and learned a lesson
about sacrifice to save your friends
that said the Ahsoka series at least now
seems to be flirting with the idea of
calling to people through time and
referencing the loath Wolves and the
gods of mortis so the world Between
Worlds episode is essential watching in
episode 14 of Fool's hope Hera Rex and
callus recruit Hondo Gregor and wolf and
ketu from CEOs Ryder pretends to betray
the rebels to price who attacks their C
dwelling but it was Ryder's ruse to lure
price out of her protection at the
capital and Ezra gets back up from the
loath wolves it kind of recalls the
large Ferno that appeared behind Ezra in
the season 1 episode on an axis but now
Ezra is fully in control which brings us
to the finale episodes 15 and 16 family
reunion and farewell this episode
actually begins as kind of a hoped for
family reunion between Ezra and his
parents showing a point of vulnerability
for Ezra that we'll see later in this
two-part finale the rebels used price to
infiltrate the Imperial based on low
fall and Ryder aaditi HS an Ezra to
impersonate Admiral Ulen to order
protocol 13 to Evac the base but Rook
has alerted thraw who arrives in the
Chimera The Shield generator has
capacitors that look like the design in
the indoor bunker in Return of the Jedi
which are actually just stacked cups
that was what provided the shield for
the Death Star 2 while it was under
construction Thon begins blasting
civilian sections of lothal and Ezra
confronts Thon alone and leaves his
lightsaber behind with chopper and suban
gives Ezra a knowing look while she
distracts the others to let him go you
got to imagine she carries a bit of
guilt with her and th quarters he is
framed perfectly between the isiri the
lizards from Air of the Empire which are
Force immune which is just kind of
ironic that he has these two Force
immune creatures that are on either side
of him when he is not immune to the
forces of nature you also notice he
still has his Jedi guard mask on his
desk thron and Palpatine we learn have
removed parts of the lothal Jedi Temple
to the Chimera and inside Ezra sees his
mother calling to him just as a Buu
called to Luke and twin Sons Thon and
Palpatine are essentially doing good cop
bad cop and Palpatine says you know it
is possible to change fade Palpatine
knows Ezra knows it's possible because
he saw him in the world Between Worlds
as Ezra destroys the temple he Sprints
through Palpatine's Hol projection as it
flickers into his true form of Darth
cius and we hear the emperor's
theme Hera and the others get the loal
shield back online and the ghost arrives
with a vast pod of Perle returning from
Season 2 Episode 15 the call and now
they are responding to the call from
Ezra they wipe out the fleet tentacles
smashing Through the Windows and
wrapping around thraw charging up to
jump into hyperspace it's up to all of
you now and Remember the force will be
with you always and this way we come
full circle with bendo's prediction of
thron's defeat in the season 3 finale
what what do you see I see your defeat
like many arms surrounding you in a gold
Embrace but is Thon truly defeated the
Ahsoka series explores how Thon and Ezra
followed these pgle on the path to
peridia and thon's fate of many arms
surrounding him in a cold Embrace made
may take on yet another meaning at some
point in the future let's also not
forget the evolutionary link between
wolves and whales the reason whales are
sea mammals is that in the distant past
there was a wolf ancestor who lived
close to water and lived more and more
of its life swimming eventually evolving
into whales they have a common ancestry
like Ezra and Kanan they are Kindred so
the rebels launch and blow up the base
they play a Holo recording from Ezra I
couldn't have wished for a better
family I can't wait to come home now we
learn in Ahsoka that Ezra recorded a
longer personal recording just for Bean
where it sounded like he actually
intended to disappear how much time did
he have to record stuff so then we jump
to an epilogue that takes place after
the battle of Endor after Return of the
Jedi and mirroring the opening shot of
the series Sabine now leans on the
railing of the loal comms Tower looking
out over the city but instead of a star
destroyer over her head it's ahsoka's T6
shuttle and x-wings a story board that
da Fon also reused for Ahsoka episode 1
Sabine has cut her hair even shorter and
now her armor Bears a pauldron with a
burgle on it we find out Zeb has taken
callus toan to prove that the lat
species was not extinct we learn that
Hera fought in the Battle of indoor Rex
fought in the Battle of indor too and
now she has a son Jason syndulla kanan's
son Spectre 7 also similar framing to
the shots of Ahsoka episode 2 but I much
prefer this version Ahsoka wears white
robes and carries a staff which day
filon intended to look like Gandalf the
White the incomplete Mentor returning as
someone who is further down the path of
Enlightenment the two go off in search
of Ezra Bridger and end of series Ahsoka
begins with them on the other side of
that search Master and Apprentice
apparently having failed to connect but
you know what on its own this Rebels
finale is perfect it brings to an end
all of these characters ARS in such a
great way and he could tell de filon
really wanted to stick that Landing
considering initially Clone Wars ended
in kind of this open-ended State okay
that was the four seasons of Star Wars
Rebels now if you only have time to
watch about one season's worth of
episodes like 23 episodes here are the
most important episodes to watch season
by season okay for season 1 episode 1
and episode two spark of the Rebellion
part 1 and two season 1 episode 5 rise
of the Old Masters season 1 episode 10
path of the Jedi season 1 episode 15
That season finale fire across the
Galaxy season 2 episode 11 Legacy season
2 episode 18 shroud of darkness and
season 2 episodes 21 and 22 the finale
of that season Twilight of The
Apprentice part 1 and two season 3
episode 1 and two steps into Shadow part
1 and two season 3 episode 11 visions
and voices season 3 episode 15 Trials of
the dark saers season 3 episode 20 twin
Suns and the finale episode season 3
episode 21 and 2 Zero Hour part 1 and
two and then season 4 episode 7 Kindred
season 4 episode 10 Jedi Knights season
4 episode 11 Doom season 4 episode 12
wolves and aore season 4 episode 13 a
world Between Worlds and season 4
episode 15 and 16 the series finales
family reunion and farewell Parts one
and two so 23 episodes yeah I left out
some but this I think are the must
watches okay and from these to really
narrow it down for you here are what I
think are the top five episodes of
rebels at least my favorites number five
a world Between Worlds obviously very
important episode four visions and
voices which is such an important mall
and dark saber episode and night Sister
episode episode three twin Sons which is
really just great for the ma Kenobi
moment episode two trials of the dark
saber I think the most important episode
to watch for any season of the
Mandalorian in episode one by far the
best Arc of the rebels series the season
2 finale Twilight of The Apprentice
Parts one and two I hope you enjoyed
this Rebels breakdown compilation please
support our Channel by grabbing some
merch at nerd riot. shop subscribe to
all three channels of the new rockstars
Network you can follow me at eaos follow
new rockstars thanks for watching and
I'll see you next time
bye